hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
Aleister McIntyre about halfway through
his essay playing persons and moral
philosophy is going to talk in terms of
a story of the decline and fall of the
plain person now he I mean it could
extend to things like health and uh you
know wealth and stuff like that but what
he's really talking about is a
intellectual and moral decline an
intellectual decline insofar as it has
to do with the entire moral or ethical
sphere and people do in fact get
themselves screwed up in trying to
figure out what is the good for human
beings or what is the good for me and
something that McIntyre says at the
start of of this discussion which we do
want to take into account it's a little
bit too strong with formulation virtues
rules and goods have to be understood in
their interrelationship or not at all it
is possible to isolate these out from
each other and to understand you know
rules and goods in some sense but not
adequately not how they really are
connected with each other and he uses
the example of people doing mathematics
you know a very important practice that
is governed by the goal of attaining
Truth somebody could come along and you
know be like well you know we could do
other things with mathematics let's
focus on this instead like making tons
of money okay mathematics could be a
useful tool in some respects but you're
inevitably going to screw up the process
of developing people into good
mathematicians by doing that
we could multiply this over and over
again with with other examples and he
says it is the outcome of fragmenting
into independent Parts the conceptual
scheme in terms of which the plain
person had at first organized his or her
moral understanding Goods rules and
virtues as a result of such
fragmentation are reconceived as
isolable from one another so the problem
is not how to articulate a pre-existing
relationship a relationship that's
already there that we sort of inherit
and step into but to construct a
relationship apparently not yet
established between the disparate parts
of the moral scheme
once you start doing that each of these
parts assumes a somewhat different
character rules conceived apart from
virtues and goods are not the same as
rules conceived Independence upon
virtues and goods likewise for virtues
apart from rules and goods and goods
apart from rules and virtues so this is
getting us to the very first part of
what he's going to call this story of
Decline and fall a story in four
episodes a story of a failed quest for
what proves in the end to be an illusory
Grail well now what does McIntyre mean
by this illusory Grail
he doesn't actually tell us here but
given the parallel between this and the
master argument in his book after virtue
we can say some sort of system of
morality or a moral theory and you know
and ethics which would convince
everybody which would be
um
universally applicable and recognized as
such you're just not going to get that
why because you have to develop a
certain amount of Virtues along the way
that have to do with rules and goods and
how we understand them
in order to even recognize the right
direction to go in so he says that in
the first part the first episode the
protagonist sets out to discover what
the final good for being such as her
himself is and finds that and asking
what is my good and what is the good in
any way that's well designed to secure
helpful answers they have to Define that
quest in a way that presupposes to a
significant degree a particular kind of
answer to these questions okay so this
is McIntyre you cannot avoid commitment
to some sort of moral stance or Theory
even if you think you're doing meta
ethics even if you think that you're
being completely neutral you're not
because that's also a bunch of moral
stances and moral theories you just
can't get away from it
so the question isn't which
should I commit myself to at this point
it's rather which have I committed
myself to and we are in fact making
presuppositions now some of them are
going to offer us ways to understand
rules and develop virtues some of them
not quite so much and we need like he
says these rules and virtues which guide
one reliably in the earliest stages of
fruitful moral inquiry presuppose a
great deal about the existence and
nature of that same good so you know if
you decide early on that like your
Supreme good is wealth or security which
are not bad things
you're going to screw yourself up
because you're going to orient your very
person your desires that you indulge the
the desires that you say no to the rules
that you follow or whatever else you
want to call it maxims Proverbs ways of
organizing yourself the things that you
consider to be
character traits that you need to
develop you're going to do so in such a
way as to miss a superior good and
um
McIntyre is going to talk about a
circularity here and the circularity
requires of us an asceticism or at least
a temperateness being able to control
your desires for Pleasures or to avoid
pains or things like that temperateness
in a broader sense self-control with
less than Supreme Goods so you know if
the Supreme good is let's just take
Aristotle for example virtuous activity
which requires that you have the virtues
along with a certain amount of wealth
and good relationships and you think
that no no I just need to focus on
wealth I'll get that wealth and then
I'll buy myself some virtues and I'll
buy myself relationships whoa you are
going to screw yourself up I mean you're
going to pursue wealth in an intemperate
way and this is going to lead to as he
says a discrepancy between rules and
goods he says that
um
should this person be solicited by a
variety of such Goods physical aesthetic
and intellectual uh fail in this
temperateness they will debar themselves
from ever reaching the point where
rational justification would become
possible but they will and according
independent recognition to a
multiplicity of more or less immediate
Goods they're going to adopt a set of
standards of justification very
different from that towards an
understanding of which they had
originally been moving so we get a
radical discrepancy between rules and
obedience to which the quest was to have
been conducted and the multiplicity of
goods possibly as rival candidates for
the status of the Supreme good possibly
even excluding the notion of a single
Supreme good and so the person is now
getting more confused about what they
ought to be doing in their life and you
know they're probably projecting this
confusion into their relationships their
workplace their families how they order
the activities that they're involved in
and then that leads us to a third
episode
in this story and we find that as he
says
the protagonist discovers not only that
she or he must take sides on these
issues you can't avoid taking sides but
that other people take similar opposing
sides right so that's going to lead to
intellectual and moral conflict that
will come to but why does this happen
well like he says
the discrepancy is resolved in either of
two incompatible ways or you could jump
to square four right but uh typically
this is what happens
so we could prioritize rules over goods
and say well we just got to follow the
actual rules hopefully they're the right
ones and we're not so worried about
whether the rules reliably you know lead
to the attainment of the goods or we say
no no no the rules have to be subject to
the goods the goods are really what's
most important and McIntyre says
um you know whichever these two is is
adopted new problems are engendered
if Conformity to moral rules is now to
be valued only for its own sake as in
Kant for example sort of Kant is the
Paradigm of that then the person
inescapably the question inescapably
arises of why and how a rational person
should be moved to Value such conformity
what is underlying that
Kant doesn't really have a great answer
for that actually deontologists in
general wind up coming back to I mean
what's right is right and duty is Duty
and you should do that right
we could go the other way if he says if
rules are only a means to the
achievement of goods and a multiplicity
of competing goods are acknowledged as
they are by say utilitarians then it
will be necessary to decide how to
respond on those occasions when the
actions necessary for the attainment of
some one particular good violate the
rule or rules necessary for the
attainment of some good so you know two
main
Alternatives we could probably have
others as well but I think McIntyre is
right in saying these are the two big
tendencies that people have let's follow
the rules the procedures obey the
authorities or let's think about how we
you know harmonize or prioritize these
goods and if the rules agree with them
great otherwise you know reform the
rules and this does lead to intellectual
and moral conflict because you find out
that
not everybody sees it your way
or even within these things right
there's different kinds of utilitarians
there's different kinds of deontologists
and the plain person is not there
reading Khan's groundwork or bentham's
introduction to the principles of uh
morals and legislation they're just sort
of doing this in a everyday way because
these are common tendencies in in life
and so realization that not everybody
agrees about these matters this can be
quite jarring
right there are no rational criteria
shared between the contending parties
fundamental disagreement as we're going
to see in the fourth turns out to be
irresolvable right and so our
protagonist like he says confronts a
variety of antagonists and perhaps him
or herself
with a divided mind on these divisive
issues so we go then to the final stage
the final episode of this discovery that
we can't rationally resolve these
matters whether it's with other people
or even in ourselves
so you know this is going to be a
significant
problem we started out wanting to know
what is the good how do I attain it
right what should I be doing what rules
do I need to follow what virtues do I
need to cultivate what good should I be
prioritizing and we get here and we find
out well there's lots of answers and no
universally agreed upon no rational way
of convincing everybody about that and
he says that it's not that the
contending parties don't have arguments
to deploy
but they give different way to different
kinds of consideration so we don't have
agreed upon rational criteria there is
more than one way in which our
protagonist might respond to this
discovery and so he mentions too you
could just become cynical and be like
well I'm just going to get whatever I
can right everything becomes
transactional or you're like all these
philosophical points of view are BS or
you could become like he says the plain
person's version of a protonachian one
devoted to unmasking a Will To Power
disguised by the proponents of each
unman each contending moral standpoint
and I I would say in our present day we
see a lot of people doing this both on
the the right and on the left you know
very selectively right this protonichian
thing but you could also just make some
non-rational commitment to some moral
theory you could say listen I understand
that there's some problems with
conscientism but it looks good to me
because I'm a very Duty driven person I
like that kind of thing and it's an
emotional Choice rather than a rational
choice right
so McIntyre goes on and he says I've
told this story of the transformations
of the plain person only in Bear and
skeletal outline and then he goes on and
he says you know this is not just a
story about one ordinary person
we can talk about this in terms of
culture he says the story could have
been told and I have told it elsewhere
in after virtue as a claim about the
narrative history of a set of successive
periods in Western culture from the 6th
to the 20th century there's a partial
mirroring as he says of the fate of
individuals in the history of the larger
social order and the fate of that larger
order right so there's the decline in
Fall isn't just individuals making
mistakes it's also something that's
replicated within our larger culture in
the workplace in Academia in healthcare
we could go on and on and on and on so
this is a very interesting short
skeletal as he says in outline Narrative
of Decline and fall how people wind up
screwing themselves up getting things
wrong and ending up in some sort of
situation where they can't really make
moral progress in any
rational
well-planned out way that jibes with
that of other people